and all week long here on good day las
vegas we're helping you get back to work
and here to join us this morning with
some
resume tips some interview tips for you
to get back into the workforce nina
griffin is here from the
one stop career center nina thanks for
joining us this morning thank you just
call me the job lady
job lady i like that it makes a lot
easier for me too we'll talk about this
mock resume in a second here but nina
let's just talk about what the job
market is like right now we keep hearing
about how restaurants and all these
businesses
need workers what is the demand like
across southern nevada right now
well just like the housing market is hot
the job market is hotter yeah
so you need to get in where you fit in
and we'd love to help you do that yeah
we know there's so many job fairs
happening around the valley right now
okay so let's talk about
just a resume here we have a mock resume
right here
what are some do's and don'ts what do
people need to know what do they need to
put down what are
employers looking for when they're
trying to hire someone right now
all right well we got to get through it
pretty quickly yeah i would like to
point out a few things
uh you have the address here let's take
that off for identity theft purposes and
then if you
publish it in the public like indeed.com
or monster.com
guess what you have your home out your
home address phone number you
they have everything so it's not
necessary in addition to that
i love lori vegas name hey lori
in addition to that we have a phone
number the phone number should be a
working phone number in addition to that
you want to clear out your messages how
can someone set up an interview with you
and your message is full
in addition to that it needs to be
appropriate not so much music
people need to hear your voice if
necessary and then lastly
let's party at hotmail well come on lori
let's party
we need to have a more generic email
address so that somebody's like
i don't know if i want to hire them yeah
email addresses are free by the way i
don't need to spend any money on that
but
there's also some important things if
you're an employee and you're trying to
separate resumes one from the other
little things like spelling mistakes
things along those lines way to get that
yourself across uh concisely can be so
important
right let's point that out i'm glad you
brought that up i'm a spelling nerd by
the way
right we have professional objective
professional is spelled wrong
it's spelled wrong here it's spelled
wrong here this is not baseball folks
it's not three strikes you're out it's
one strike you're out
i would suggest that you read it out
loud use spell check
and have someone look it over for you
what are some other tips just in terms
of maybe formatting of what the resume
should look like
when you're putting it together i feel
like some folks end up with a blank
screen they don't know what to do
right well the thing is is that we can
help you that at the one stop we can
help you with formatting
it all depends on who your target
audience is but i'd like to look down at
employment history
we have various dates here but we see
one here that says 1995.
i think you should just limit it to the
first 10 years if there's anything else
they need to know they can talk to you
about that in the interview
what's important is that you have the
skills and that you did what you said
is on the resume one last thing we have
references upon request
if you say their references are upon
request you need to make sure they're
available in addition to that they could
be professional they could be personal
but you need to contact the person who's
going to be your reference and say hey
look i need you
so very quickly here before we go you've
got the resume locked in let's say
you're ready to go and you get to have
an interview
what are some ways to stand out when
you're actually face to face whether
it's virtually or in person
with a potential employer well the first
thing you want to do is to be on time
nobody should be waiting for you
in addition to that i should say check
out the company website you should know
something about the company that you're
going to be working for
practice i have something right here
that most of us have that's called a
cell phone
you know what you want to save a
elevator pitch or your introduction for
about 30 seconds shouldn't go longer
than that
smile be positive take your time watch
the you knows
and the um and the blinking in addition
to that
after the interview is over you'd like
to ask the person who's interviewing you
for their business card or how to
contact them in a few days follow up
with the thank you
thank yous go a long way in case they're
trying to decide guess what that puts
you back up to the top of the pile
well thank you very much for joining us
this morning you know we appreciated
some
tips to hopefully get you a job right
now again so many businesses are hiring
right now but in order to get a job you
got to get this locked down your resume
get your interviewing locked down as
well
we have a full list of companies that
are hiring here in the valley head to
eight newsnow dot com you can click on
the job board tab
and links are there to apply as well
again nina thank you very much from the
one stop career center can i give out
our website go for it our website is
envycareercenter.org all the services
that we provide are at no cost come on
down see the job lady we have 11
locations open at this time
thank you we'll have that
editnewsnow.com as well